[Música]
después del fallido motín del grupo
Wagner son varios los militares rusos
que ya no aparecen en público por lo que
hay rumores de una supuesta purga que
podría estar llevando a cabo el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin entre sus
funcionarios se habla de al menos un
encarcelamiento de uno de sus generales
que hay de cierto en estas afirmaciones
lo vamos a conversar con Martín bañales
doctor en historia por la universidad de
Buenos Aires Bienvenido a France 24 el
portavoz del kremlin Dimitri pescott
dijo no tener información del General
serge urobiki quien También conocido
como general Armagedón y pidió a los
periodistas referirse al Ministerio de
defensa se cree que sudovica tuvo
conexión con el motín que se sabe hasta
el momento
bueno efectivamente
las informaciones son bastante confusas
y y por cuentagotas de hecho todavía no
sabemos bien de qué se trata O Qué
contiene el arreglo que que hicieron
después del motín el gobierno de Putin y
el líder del grupo Wagner Washington se
mantiene dentro de una zona de
información reservada generando rumores
que pueden ayudar por un lado a
debilitar pero también a generar un
apoyo más grande todavía al gobierno de
Putin que se vio debilitado después de
del motín de Wagner de la semana pasada
de modo que las informaciones respecto
de este tipo de situaciones tan
delicadas como es la purga a figuras
principales del ejército ruso no van a
ser puestas de manifiesto porque esto
podría interpretarse también como una
señal debilitamiento del gobierno de
Putin yo creo que Putin va a esperar un
tiempo prudencial para tomar decisiones
drásticas como puede ser por ejemplo
la purga en el ejército o El reemplazo
de alguna figura importante dentro del
gobierno del gabinete Como por ejemplo
puede ser el ministro de defensa porque
quiere ver o quiere estar al tanto pues
quiere estar bien seguro de la reacción
que eso puede generar si algo
caracteriza Putin es que cualquier tipo
de reforma importante él la va a
realizar o la viene realizando como lo
hizo en el pasado Con un fuerte control
del efecto que pueden tener esas
reformas tanto en el gobierno como en la
sociedad bueno en este mismo sentido le
pregunto también por el jefe del Estado
Mayor por Valery querasimo fa quien
tampoco se ha visto Cuál es su teoría
respecto a él
bueno Y tanto que nacimos como
el ministro de defensas fueron las
figuras apuntadas por privaciones decir
que en ese sentido es una conducta
podríamos decir este lógica y atinada
como para bajar un poco el el el el foco
de atención de lo que fue la lo que
fueron las demandas de pregon la semana
pasada en ese sentido se corren de
escena se distrae de alguna manera la
atención de lo que fueron las demandas
de las personas amputadas por privado
sino que olvidar que incluso ya desde
antes del motín
primosin el líder del grupo Wagner venía
haciendo reclamos este con incluso
modales exagerados tanto a jibu como a
gracimos respecto de por ejemplo el
suministro de bienes para seguir
combatiendo en el frente entonces son
dos figuras tanto que hacemos como como
que salieron lastimadas de este intento
de motín y por lo tanto Es lógico que se
corran ahora Graciela como ya había
sucedido el año pasado en distintos
momentos cuando los resultados no eran
los esperados que por ejemplo el propio
joyú había salido de escena había estado
fuera de la escena pública por varias
semanas y después retornó cuando la
situación se había calmado bueno Y
tenemos igual que hablar de baja no
tenemos que hablar según lo que dice el
kremlin no hay conocimiento Exacto del
paradero de prigollín se puede decir que
el grupo Wagner quedó desconfigurado
cómo está ejerciendo control Moscú en
estos momentos
claramente va a haber cambios pero como
te decía anteriormente vamos por el modo
en el cual el gobierno ruso suele
manejar algunos aspectos institucionales
no sabemos Qué arreglo hubo entre
el líder de Wagner y el propio gobierno
de Putin eso es un misterio todavía no
no se hizo público lo que sí que está
claro que va a haber este cambios que ya
no va a tener el mismo peso que tenía
antes Y esto también es un problema para
el gobierno de Putin porque Putin
utilizaba este ejército privado para
algunas acciones con las cuales no podía
contar con el gobierno con el ejército
regular no esto se puso de manifiesto en
Siria en África o incluso en el propio
territorio ucraniano No ahora sino este
en 2014 Cuando comenzó el conflicto en
la región de del dombas al mismo tiempo
el gobierno de Putin no puede contar con
ese ejército privado incluso dentro del
propio de la propia Rusia con lo cual
podría hacer frente a una eventual
rebelión que pudiera llegar a ver dentro
del territorio y que pudiera poner en
peligro la continuidad del del gobierno
ruso de modo que
hay cambios no sabemos el alcance y
tampoco sabemos muy bien Cuál es eh
Cuáles son específicamente esos cambios
porque el como te decía el el contenido
del acuerdo que se hizo entre bagnet y
el propio Putin es un misterio bueno Y
si se sabía desde mucho tiempo antes
esta relación entre el kremlin y Wagner
pero Putin reconoció tras la
insurrección que el fisco ruso financió
a Wagner Durante un año esto ya es otro
nivel de información como cae que
refleja Esto del accionar del gobierno
ruso
bueno por un lado no es algo que
sorprenda al gobierno ruso tiene una
manera de manejar los asuntos del estado
más basado no tanto en reglas
institucionales sino en relaciones más
de tipo informales No eso se ve por
ejemplo en el caso de las gobernaciones
de las distintas provincias en el caso
del manejo de este determinadas empresas
estratégicas Y en este caso en
particular en la Constitución de un
ejército de un ejército privado es decir
que no forma parte del ejército regular
ruso que se sostiene y se viene
sosteniendo como reconoció ahora el
propio Putin con aportes estatales no
esto generó digamos dentro de la de la
población un malestar importante porque
se suma a otros elementos que apuntan a
prácticas corruptas o de desvío de
fondos hacia
elementos que forman que este
extraoficiales así que nos forman parte
de la estructura del estado y pudo
ayudar a debilitar la figura de Putin
esto también marca también el
el interés y un poco un poco los móviles
que tuvo el brigosing con el grupo
Wagner durante su motín porque a partir
del primero de julio y van a quedar
desactivados esos aportes hacia el grupo
Wagner se buscaba la integración de los
integrantes de Wagner al ejército
regular Y eso lo puso en alerta a
privación porque suponía el el fin o por
lo menos las disminución importante de
esos aportes que provenían desde el
estado para el ejército privado de modo
que bueno Esto afectó la multa de este
aporte que realizaba el estado en
términos de dinero para Wagner afectó a
los dos a los dos sectores de la misma
manera
Bueno quiero ahondar un poco en su
perspectiva sobre Cómo quedó la posición
del presidente Putin y también de joyú
con este con esta insurrección de alguna
manera se vieron afectados su imagen se
vio debilitada o por el contrario esto
les puede servir para impulsarse
Bueno yo creo que sí que a priori quedó
la imagen de Putin quedó tocada quedó
debilitada Y eso se puso de manifiesto
por ejemplo en la acción propagandística
del kremling que enseguida salió a
mostrar cosa que no sucedía
habitualmente por lo menos desde la
pandemia a un Putin cercano a la a la
gente no estuvo imágenes incluso
afirmaciones de Putin abrazando a
ciudadanos rusos en en una de sus
visitas al sur del del país como para
mostrar a un presidente tanto este
cercano a la población como fuerte no
porque ese es el impacto que tuvo el
motín de
Wagner en el de poder debilitar o
Mostrar que una acción de este tipo es
posible en Rusia y que nadie lo detenga
no porque el grupo Wagner avanzó tanto
en la ciudad de rostov y y prácticamente
sin ningún tipo de resistencia con lo
cual esto vamos genera una alerta dentro
del gobierno genera una posibilidad de
que eventualmente en el futuro pueda
dentro de la élite realizarse algún tipo
de acción que pueda generar un cambio de
figuras dentro del gobierno
ruso no tanto en la figura del ministro
de defensa yo que eso todavía le le
dejaría a a Putin un margen de maniobra
pero sí al propio presidente no con lo
cual ahí sería el fin de su gobierno y
el fin de su carrera política Martín
pues le agradezco este análisis nosotros
estamos teniendo problemas de conexión y
por eso tuvimos que suspender esta
entrevista ustedes también Les
agradecemos su sintonía hacemos una
pausa en directo a América ya regresamos
[Música]